oggi si gioca hello kitty preparatevi
bene tutti ragazzi ma scusate ragazzi
benvenuti questo video sono file giorgi
siamo nessun game allora e tipo un ecco
questo pare che ho fatto diabete tipo
residenti ball fatto di un pene ho visto
incredibile
volevo assolutamente dargli una
possibilità mi sembra veramente carino
sei solo un principiante spaventata
dalla sua stessa ombra
forse è meglio iniziare dai ma con un
ciuccio insieme a qualche risorsa in più
e nemici più deboli brutta pool per
cento va praticamente successo va a
riassumo che c'è stato questo specie
successo qualcosa in un laboratorio e la
gente inizia ad attaccare altra gente
come succede tra noi youtubers alle
fiere bellissimo allora infiltrati nel
centro di ricerca va a moreau allora che
lo scrivo perché sono sorpreso da tutto
questo gioco è fatto da una casella
dipendente di carcere da quattro persone
l'hanno fatto non ultime quattro suoi
parenti avevano fatto però veramente
l'hanno fatto un dipendente come diavolo
è possibile porca vacca è veramente
splendido diavolo come hanno fatto a
fare sta roba
vi giuro vi ammazzo se vi alzate tratto
che sono entrata in un centro attrazione
il laboratorio scendo a cazzotti la
gente una pistolina me l'avete data
immaginano esatto proprio lui reattiva
tutte attivato la corrente ragazzi cioè
fatta nava mi sa che non andiamo salve
ascolti fermo ho detto fermo ho detto
fermo non lo so però è svenuto
fortissimo e che mi rende orgoglioso di
me stesso no ho capito che se tu carichi
le così per metà lasci proiettili per
terra e quindi poi tavi intercooler
quindi se tutto andò carichi devi tenere
più premuto il caricatore in modo tale
che carica molto più lento però non
lascia il caricatore per terra
teoricamente quindi bellissimo questa
dinamica è veramente geniale pd tu puoi
caricare più veloce lasciare il
caricatore per terra e poi recuperare
se tutti i nuovi o ti ammazzo questa
cosa devi capire sono molto contento di
questa cosa va beh l'importante che ho
attivato la corrente vediamo se riesco a
trovare qualche è di chi tocca catina
perfetto ma adesso mi devo aspettare
qualsiasi cosa quindi ci sono gli zombie
ufficialmente praga ricordiamoci come
sono qualità più o meno difficile quindi
secondo me questo gioco sarà abbastanza
un casino però fa niente
diamo avanti avanti avanti avanti a
prima porta prima porta prima volta
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
l'archivio porta qui la porta chi la
porta chiudi la porta la porta la forte
la porta c'è sempre gente che si alza
l'aveva niente 128 mancato 3
mamma mia come mi hanno preso nelle
patatine come slot ho trovato la
richiesta di ammissione nelle forze
speciali dentro le wacko's che erano
quelle patatine vi ricordate
ho notato che se qualcuno si alza ma tu
corri non ti segue quando è qui questa è
una cosa molto importante se vogliamo
risparmiare punizioni ragazzi nel corso
della storia vai attenzione rilevata a
celje vorrei dirvi questo gioco eppure
tradotto totalmente in italiano e che
incredibile la carbonara necessità di
pizzino a numana attiva del processo
ripristino massimi tanto sono anche la
detto elettricista oltre che il tizio
delle forze speciali è finora stato io
porco demonio è una domanda vorrei fare
se è possibile farla e vorrei una
risposta quanto prima se non ho colpi da
utilizzare tiro schiaffi sì ma io ce li
ho i miei compagni in tutta questa
storia versi perché porca vacca
questo potrebbe essere un problema 1
losco demonio non ho capito di quello
che mi si dirà mi nuovo por con le mani
si alzano cori
ci manca solo questo bisogno devo fare
non ho capito l'obiettivo attiva il
montacarichi nell'area di carica adesso
l'ho capito ci sono equi maledizione ma
che non ha veramente su troppi devi
schiattare mandorla che scalzò che
picchia la gente
no ragazzi se gli offrono si bloccano
non si blocca non sempre in uno che
potrebbe sembrare sono morto mi ha
vomitato della roba dell'omogeneizzato
in faccia io già non ho più che ho
iniziato il gioco non ho già più colpi
sono qua da un minuto e ne ho già perso
non colpì porca vacca non possono anche
lasciarli come si fa il corpo a corpo ha
deciso che non mi vuole tirare file
botte sto tizio prima le tirava nelson
più rai
avevano il campione che devo recuperare
il vento questa camera di stoccaggio ok
trova modo per sbloccare la camera di
stoccaggio virus chiamo pietro
lui è bravo in queste cose attivare per
sé non è anche letto alla cisterna ci
penso io credo che siamo visti tutto qua
tutto qua iori valuterei un attimo il
mio diploma torna indietro
eccolo qui qui ecco questo non mi non è
il massimo però carino questo mi sa che
dura questo mi sa queste sono morto lo
picchiò a qualcosa va come possibile ma
dai
lo sparatutto 100 corpi non si è fatto
niente gli ho tirato un pugno e 6
stordito facciamo finta che non ti ho
sparato neanche proprio la roba che non
è tra i colpi perché non sono niente di
vero subito schifo è schioppa non è
morto non muore e vabbè morirò qui è
stato bello vivere questo gioco sì che
durato va bene non fa niente facciamo
che giochi o giochi tu non è facile non
muore ma fa niente nel saper essere io
capisco che le persone ci vogliano
proietti tanti proiettive facciamo che
gli zombie in ormai adesso li picchio
basta riprende anche per il culo perché
mi dice di guardare il tutorial grazie
zio
facciamo che non lo cago era show
tornando indietro ragazzi perché è
troppo difficile
adesso aprendo il cose torna indietro
visto visto la partita che lui non c'è
prendi cosa e batte né batten e via via
prendi cosa prendi io non lo prende
crowe morto ho vissuto una bellissima
vita però ciao un cazzotto e si fa
indietro ma dai dove bisognerebbe
trovare un modo per farlo fuori tipo le
gambe avrà un punto debole su cristiano
più schifo mi son incastrato il piede in
quel coso per terra però fa niente
comunque non hanno punti deboli sti
affari come possibile se provo a
spararli tutto il tempo con il
mitragliatore che succede ma schiatta
ogni vagone robe succedono le cose mamma
prendi la camera è un casino
non volevo farti così tanto male mi
dispiace a saperlo ti picchiamo di meno
però poteva approfittarne perché si è
mossa per un bel po ma come è possibile
è il sexy lei lei stava lì per terra
fortissimo no ragazzi allora i pugni
sono fortissimi questo guarda guarda i
pugni in questo gioco cioè i pugni nelle
mani a dirmelo prima
non lo è come li sparavo di corpi in se
me lo dicevi prima lo pio a pugni subito
poi comunque non è che muore si
stordisce gli rimane stordito ma per
quale motivo è schioppa bene allora
mentre stordito io prendo le cose e poi
vado avanti
bellissimo dai dov'è che devo prendere
quel cor dove devo andare a di qualità
attention così che il quarantenne
attivato ok disco devi stare per terra
se ti picchia per terra dai per terra
dai giu bravo ormai praticamente insieme
ma scusatemi ma come è possibile
vi giuro io voglio aver sparato 2000
colpi ma come è possibile
ma vedi che si conta spiega minuto visto
che di che si può entrare a scuotere la
finestra questo scavalcare non posso
correre
c'è la corsa ai suoi comandi che non
conosceva bene possiamo telo per lo più
in corsa fortissimo destro mentre collo
ciao scusa mi sto cercando di capire box
spiega tiburon achievement aiuto
ragazzi se non muore così non muore
prima lo assicuro è morto credo sia
morto perché è sparita la musica invece
al braccio incastrato di là non sono
completamente sicuro che sia morto però
vediamo una fabbrica assistiamo sono
come avrebbe fatto prendere stato bello
però un po difficile a buttar giù pro
bello
cercatemi altri colpi perché va bene ti
dicevo arrivo a como il che bisognava
trovare di che in quegli stupidi che non
sanno sopravvivere cosa che cosa ne
fosse io se loro sono competenti qual è
il mio problema ma che ormai weymuth
sorella
ed ora devo salvare i miei compagni
stupidi ci manca solo quello dei ragazzi
concluso di un episodio bellissimo per
adesso damon no veramente stupendo per
essere un gioco fatto da molto bello
brevi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale
schiacciatela campanellina vicino al
basso iscriviti mitili menta giovani
sono i video e noi come sempre ci
vediamo hanno proseguito della ragazza
[Musica]